well guys it is finally time for me to
start talking about my picks for the
best films in 2012 let me give you a
little disclaimer I have not yet seen
zero dark thirty that film won't be on
this list because it doesn't open in
Cleveland until January 11th and my
screening isn't until the 10th I tried
very hard to get a DVD screener of that
film from Sony Pictures but they just
don't want anyone outside of New York
and LA to see that film yet so it's not
going to be on my list I do however have
some great movies to talk about with you
guys but before I get to them I just
want to remind you that I did see the
place beyond the pines at Toronto
International Film Festival in September
and I did give that film an A+ but that
phone doesn't come out until March of
2013 so that film won't be on this list
and one more thing before I get into my
list you guys are going to see certain
films on this list for you're like wait
a second he gave that one an A and that
one at a - so why is the a - one above
the a or why is the a plus one lower
than the ones that's a or a - you're
going to see that on this list maybe a
film that did everything just right in
the way it should be and I gave an A+
perhaps for like a different film even
more even if it didn't get that highest
grade this is just my one weird chance
in a video where I can be a hundred
percent completely just biased and give
you guys my opinion so let's get started
first off I have five honorable mentions
count of five this was a great year for
movies and these five films were so good
that I can't think about making a list
without them they have to be on here in
some way my first honorable mention is
compliance this was a deeply disgusting
and disturbing movie not in your saw or
hostel sense of violence but in a very
morally - based way and the very sad
thing is it was a true story and the
details were depicted with intense
scrutiny great film got under my skin
my next honorable mention is a brilliant
piece of filmmaking Paul Thomas Anderson
is the master I love this movie it was
so well made so well acted still has
possibly what I think is the best
performance of the year in joaquin
phoenix it's a movie that was shot so
well that in 2d almost had the same
effect that a 3d film has on your eyes
it leapt out at you at the movie I felt
like my eyes had taken in too much
beauty such a great film very divisive
however extremely well done my third
honorable mention is end of watch an
incredible cop drama with Jake
Gyllenhaal and Michael Pena this is a
movie that
had some of the best chemistry I've seen
all year it was a funny action-packed
heartbreaking film and I talked to a
buddy of mine who's actually a cop and
he said it was just so authentic the way
cops actually are in real life stuff
they go through great movie now you may
be surprised this is an honorable
mention due to the fact that I gave this
film an A+
I adore moonrise kingdom I love that
movie it is so well done in my opinion
for the type of movie it was trying to
be it did everything just right it's a
funny hilarious quirky extremely well
shot adventure and it's kind of like a
fantasy in a lot of ways but I love this
film so much and the only reason it's
not actually on my list is because there
are other films that I did enjoy more
but for the film that was trying to be I
thought it did absolutely everything
right and my last honorable mention is
probably the most controversial film in
this entire video prometheus a lot of
people were bored by this movie a lot of
people were disappointed by this movie a
lot of people wanted alien aliens and
they wanted this to be like that it
wasn't nevertheless if you saw my
Prometheus explained video I mentioned
that I feel like this is one of those
movies that once the hype dies down and
they stop thinking about it as an alien
film or you know just in the way the
trailers depicted it or whatever that it
will eventually be looked at as a much
more mature science fiction film when I
watch the blu-ray special features I
think it blew my mind was just how much
special effects aren't in this movie
like almost the entire film was shot on
practical sets
good job Ridley Scott it may not have
been as good as alien or aliens but I
still really enjoyed your film okay no
more further ado let's get to the top 10
films of 2012 as picked by me number 10
is a film that affected me emotionally
so much and it was such a deeply real
film because I've been to high school
and I understand a lot of the things
this kid went through the perks of being
a wallflower was a film that blew me
away on so many different levels I was
so surprised that the author of the book
actually directed this movie that's
unprecedented you really don't get to
see that too many times I mean that's it
doesn't really happen that much logan
lerman performance was so well done he's
come a long way since Percy Jackson and
I was so taken by the love that he was
feeling for Emma Watson and Ezra
Miller's great performance as their
friend this movie just hit me in all the
right emotional spots The Perks of Being
a Wallflower is a very great film I hope
you guys check it out if you haven't
seen it yet at number 9 on my list is
one of my favorite directors films in my
opinion his bed
film since Munich Lincoln Lincoln also
features one of the best performances of
the year by Daniel day-lewis and a
terrific outstanding supporting world by
Tommy Lee Jones this movie just really
understood the essence of what Lincoln
was it may not have gotten everything
factually right as all film based off
true stories rarely ever do but I felt
that it really captured the essence of
that man the entire movie is almost
nothing but conversations and the fact
that I was so riveted by that just
speaks so well for how this movie was
written and directed Lincoln is
definitely one of my favorite historical
films it has terrific performances
fantastic direction check out Lincoln if
you haven't yet at number 8 on my list
is another film that just proves that an
actor can become a director and do it
extremely well
multiple times Argo after Ben Affleck
made Gone Baby Gone and impressed the
hell out of me and then he made the town
and I was like my god this is a good new
talent with Argo he absolutely 100%
solidifies that he knows what he's doing
behind the camera and one of the most
surprising things about this movie to me
was the humor it was so funny Alan Arkin
and John Goodman that comedy pair was
like some of the best comedy chemistry
I've seen this year just them together
in this movie brought it to a whole
nother level it wasn't just a really fun
thriller and engaging and suspenseful
that comedy element was so strong in the
film and it fits so well because that's
something that's really hard to do when
you kind of try to add comedy into a
more serious drama it can really come
off as forced not here it was so well
done Argo excellent movie at number 7 is
the first film that I got to see at if
it was the premiere the atmosphere in
the room was just it was so warm and
exciting everyone was pumped to see
looper Joseph gordon-levitt came out
introduced the film Rian Johnson did as
well they were so excited about it and
you can just feel that excitement
throughout this entire movie it's one of
the best science fiction films of recent
years it has terrific action but it's
not that the action overrides the
interesting story because there's real
characters there with real depth and the
science fiction element just adds to
that and gives these people more things
to work with it was such a brilliantly
edited film - I really think it might be
the best edited film I've seen all year
the musical score was different it was
engaging everything about looper just
set me there and I was just like I
haven't seen a film like this
in a long long time and it was just such
a great adrenaline shot to the veins to
see an original piece of filmmaking and
I can't wait to see what Rian Johnson
does next and number six is another film
that I got to see at if all the cast was
there the director the atmosphere in the
room was similar to looper everyone was
just so pumped to see this movie then
the audience was just dying with
laughter every couple seconds Seven
Psychopaths surprised every bone in my
body I could not believe how well made
this film was the best part of this
movie I think is the screenplay Colin
Farrell Sam Rockwell Christopher Walken
Woody Harrelson these four men gives
some of the most hilarious performances
of the year by far
they are so excellent in this movie and
they work so well together and my word
Sam Rockwell I honestly have never seen
a performance this good by him he was
fantastic in moon he's been good and
basically everything I've seen him in
but he stole every scene in this movie
and he did such an excellent job if you
have not seen Seven Psychopaths
I implore you to see that movie it is
unbelievably well done this is when it
gets serious this is when the heavy
hitters come out let's talk about one of
the first films of 2012 that just blew
me away
The Avengers this is a movie that you
know you can look at and you complain
about all kinds of things because it is
a fanboy film thus a whole bunch of
people will complain about it but at its
core it did exactly what it was trying
to do in my opinion almost perfectly it
is a fun superhero film with likable
characters good depth and incredible
action and it did it just right for a
filmmaker to be able to balance so many
larger-than-life people in one movie
give each of them enough depth to be
able to care about them that is an
impressive feat deserves to be in the
top 5 just because of that however it
was also one of the funnest most
extremely entertaining movies of the
year the Avengers was just everything a
fanboy could want all in one movie at
number four is a film by one of my
favorite filmmakers this is a guy who
has almost consistently never
disappointed Quentin Tarantino's Django
Unchained this is what I am talking
about man this is an original piece of
filmmaking that it's just fun over the
top completely just I don't care what
you think I'm putting this on the screen
that's what Tarantino does best
and here he does it so well which Ango
Unchained it was such a fun film to
watch Jamie Foxx was so great as this
guy Django but Christoph Waltz my word
what an actor that guy can really act in
a scene and he is so good at delivering
Tarantino dialogue and what in the world
was going on with Leonardo DiCaprio in
this movie he's just that guy man hmm
that guy is an actor that guy can really
inhabit a character it was so original
so different and so much fun to watch
Django Unchained you my friend are
awesome and number three we have what
was for me the biggest surprise of the
entire year silver linings playbook was
a film that just hit me and I couldn't
get out of my system I was thinking
about it for days and weeks on end and
I'm still thinking about this movie
Bradley Cooper really came into his own
in this movie this is a film that most
general audiences are going to see
before place beyond the pines which I
did see before silver linings so I knew
going into this movie that Cooper could
act because he is incredible and place
beyond the pines we'll talk about that
in next year's best on video I'm
positive but here he delivers such a
wounded vulnerable performance and that
along with Jennifer Lawrence's chemistry
her performance Robert DeNiro in this
movie Jacki Weaver so much great stuff
happening in this movie Chris Tucker
even did a great job in this movie it
was directed so well by David O'Russell
in this film just hit my emotional
dominoes it was like there's one not
gonna there's no oh god no no don't go
that far don't hit another dog the tears
are coming if you didn't get a chance to
see silver linings playbook in theaters
please rent the blu-ray or DVD when it
comes out it is well worth your time
it's an emotional experience that is
very rewarding and a lot of fun at the
same time at number two we have a film
that I was just so pumped for I was just
this was the movie man I wanted this
movie please be good and it was Skyfall
just mmm Skyfall was so awesome it's one
of the best Bond movies ever made Daniel
Craig is just the Bond Daniel Craig just
takes his character to a whole nother
level and Sam Mendes was the perfect
director to do that and Roger Deakins as
a cinematographer ah this movie was just
a complete cinematic orgasm for my
eyeballs Harvey a bar da silva this
messed up disgusting file funny villain
one of the best Bond villains ever
and Judi Dench as M ray Fiennes this
movie was just on a whole nother level
of summer blockbuster entertainment it
entertained me from every single scene
and I liked it even more the second time
I saw it it evokes this incredible
feeling of drama along with some really
intense action Skyfall is just a
magnificent piece of filmmaking and I
can't wait to buy the blu-ray and put it
with my collection alright guys my
number one pick of the year you may have
predicted it may have been able to
expect it you can call me a fanboy you
can call me whatever you want because my
opinion the film of 2012 that I will
look back and say that is the film that
just did it and it did it right it may
not have been as good as its predecessor
but nevertheless the Dark Knight Rises
is the film that just took me to places
that no other film in 2012 did how did
Bruce Wayne get back into Gotham I don't
know but he's Bruce Wayne and Batman I'm
willing to give him the benefit of the
doubt I went into this film expecting
Dark Knight - I honestly did and that
was a mistake I was expecting a non-stop
thrill ride 100% just this thriller this
intense movie and what I got was a quiet
dramatic look at such an iconic
character this film got the character of
Bruce Wayne so correct that it was able
to portray Batman
perhaps as well as any film in this
entire series even though he possibly
was in it the least amount of all of
them which is interesting Tom Hardy as
Bane just fantastic to be able to be so
over-the-top in your performance to have
almost your entire face shielded and
still be that convincing such a fun and
entertaining villain and Hathaway as
Catwoman Morgan Freeman Michael Michael
Caine in this movie makes me cry leti
makes me cry like every time that final
scene where he's like and I fail to
master Wayne I like that scene I just
can't take it it's just I'm gonna cry
right now thinking about it the finale
of this film is the most enthralling
finale of any film this year for me the
dark n Rises just hit a level of human
emotion that no superhero film ever has
and
that reason it is my number one pick of
2012 so thank you so much for watching
guys I really appreciate this and you
know I know you're not going to agree
with all my opinions and you're gonna
want to type things in all caps and be
like where's this and where's that what
about that I would put that there boy
Prometheus on this list you bastard
but it's fine and I understand that
because you know opinions they're
they're strong they're you know people
have their opinions and they want to say
I might get it these are my picks thanks
a lot for watching me this entire year
guys it's been a great and fun year I
just want to thank you so much for doing
that it really means a lot to me really
it honestly really does thank you so
much
pretty soon I'm going to be having my
top 10 picks for worst films of 2012
stay tuned for that video in just a day
or two I hope you enjoy because ha yeah
mmm there's some pics on there also
lastly I did make a tribute to my
favorite films of the year a montage in
which I tried to do my best to edit it
very well it took me a month or so to
make it I posted that on a different
channel and I really would love your
guy's opinion on that video I put that
link below and there's annotation at the
very end of this video to check that out
let me know what you thought of that I
hope you enjoy it and as always guys
thanks so much for watching me this year
and if you like this video you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
Oh